I'm gonna start with a reference to this
term of beautiful ideas and it came from
hosting a film maker about a year and a
half ago in the laboratory I just showed
you at the TJ Watson Research Center in
Yorktown Heights and it was a filmmaker
that directed this documentary called
particle fever that I don't know if
you've had a chance to watch but I
highly recommend it is about the team
that was pursuing the discovery of the
higgs boson in the largest physics
experiment ever conducted and a major
character in the film is a professor
from Stanford and at the beginning of
the film he said something that really
captivated me he said the thing that
differentiates scientists is a purely
artistic ability to discern what is a
good idea what is a beautiful idea what
is worth spending time on and most
importantly what is a problem that is
sufficiently interesting yet
sufficiently difficult that it hasn't
yet been solved but the time for solving
it has come now so I want to tell you
about this beautiful idea whose time for
solving it has come now and that is the
possibility to create quantum computers
if you look at how we have created the
basis of the information revolution and
you trace it back to other beautiful
ideas like what Shannon taught us to
think about the world of information
abstractly if you look at you know an
old punch card and DNA we've come to
appreciate that both carry something in
common they carry information and
Shannon told us that this world of bits
could be decoupled from its physical
implementation that was really
interesting but in fundamental ways it
went too far leaving too much physics
out so here is two scientists that work
ribn research Charlie Bennett on the
right continues to work in our
laboratory and is at IBM
and they asked the question at the time
of is a fundamental limit to how
efficient number-crunching can be
computing can be and when they ask that
question as physicists they ended up
with a very surprising answer and they
found the answer to be no it turns out
that number crunching can be
thermodynamically reversible this led to
an exploration of what is the
relationship between physics and
information and there was a now famous
conference that was jointly organized
between IBM Research and MIT at Endicott
house where this topic was exploring
more detail and the plenary speaker was
none other than Richard Fineman and
Fineman proposed in that conference that
if you wanted to simulate nature we
should build a quantum computer and I'm
gonna explain you what that means and
how it's created and the problems that
it will solve but first I gotta tell you
what is a fundamental idea
the fundamental idea just like we have
bits in the classical world that can be
a 0 or a 1 in a quantum computer you
have qubits which stands for quantum
bits now the difference is that they can
be a 0 a 1 or both at the same time that
exploits a principle of quantum physics
called superposition and it sounds weird
and crazy but it's true now to give you
these and ease that you should feel when
you talk about quantum information and
quantum computing I'm gonna give you a
very simple example of thought
experiment that also happens to be true
so let's imagine that we're going to
solve this problem the problem involves
you have four cards three are identical
one is different one is a queen we
shuffle the cards and we put them
facedown and the problem we're going to
solve together is find the Queen we're
going to be assisted by two computers
one is a classical computer
one is a quantum computer so what we do
is we turn them down and we load them
into memory so we use 4 memory slots
the cards are identical we put zeros the
one that has a queen we put a 1 right so
in our 4 slot we'll have three zeros and
one is a 1 we load them on the 2
computers now we ask to write a program
to find the Queen find the one how would
it be done classically you would go and
pick a random number you don't know
where it is you go look under that
memory slot see if it's a 1 if not you
go to the next slot and so on and so on
on average you would take you the
equivalent of two and a half turns to
find it it turns out that with a two
qubit quantum computer for this problem
you can always solve it in one shot so
that uneasy feeling that you have now
should be an explanation that quantum
computer is not just about building a
faster computer it is building something
that is fundamentally different than a
classical computer now a way to think
about it an abstraction of it is that a
quantum computer is always going to have
a classical computer next to it they
have to go together so you have a
classical set of bits right the problem
that you're trying to explore and what
the quantum computers can allow you to
do is to explore this exponential number
of states these 2 to the N where n is
the number of qubits that you have so
now we have relatively small quantum
computers with few qubits but just think
of the number that by the time you have
50 cubits you have 2 to the 50 states
that's a phenomenally large number but
in the end after you explore this number
of states you go back to a classical
output a string of zeros and ones that
you interpret with a normal computer so
why is this interesting and I think in
these audience I don't need to you know
explain
in great detail you know what
Exponential's mean and y22 the 50 is a
very large number but it's still I think
it's an interesting way to communicate
the power of this and I'd like to map it
to some problems but I like to go after
this apocryphal story that actually IBM
used in the 1960s to explain to people
the power of Exponential's and it had to
do with the person who invented chess
that goes to the Emperor and says well
here's this wonderful game and asks what
do you want in return and the person who
invented is give me a grain of rice on
the first day for the first square and
the second day you give me twice as much
and on the third square third day you
give me you know twice as much as the
day before and then parure greece
promptly that that seems quite
reasonable and after a week you only
have a hundred and twenty-seven grains
after a month you have more rice than
you'll eat in your lifetime for sure but
just by the time you get to the end of
the chessboard you have more rise than
Mount Everest so there are a large
number of problems in the world that
have this characteristic that they blow
up exponentially and a dirty secret in
the world of computing is that we
obviously talk a lot about all the
things that computers can solve and can
solve a lot of things but then these are
a lot of things that computers cannot
solve and very interestingly they cannot
solve it now nor ever and the reason is
because they have this exponential built
into them so take as an example this
fairly simple equation factoring so if I
have a number M that is made out of the
multiplication of two large prime
numbers and I only give you em and I ask
you find me P and Q it turns out that
that is phenomenally difficult to solve
there's no other way about 2 divided by
prime numbers so in fact it's so
difficult we use it as the base
of all encryption but if you had a very
large Universal fault-tolerant quantum
computer which is many many years away
you could solve that problem in seconds
what would take billions of years in a
classical computer that tells you
something about the power of what is
going to be possible
take chemistry as a problem because it
also has this characteristic that it
blows up exponentially if you try to
calculate it this equation that you see
here is very interesting because it's
predicted to occur at the ocean floor
near volcanic sites and famously it's
been hypothesized to be the basis of the
formation of life on Earth but if you
take a molecule like you know iron
sulfide and you try to do relatively
simple calculations with a normal
machine it turns out that we're not very
accurate and the reason is that
molecules form when electron orbitals
overlap and the calculation of each
orbital requires a quantum mechanical
calculation so for that simple molecule
you have on the order of 76 orbitals and
2 to the power of 76 is intractable with
a classical computer so we cannot solve
it again on this theme of our
assumptions that computers solve
everything but they don't if you look at
calculating for example the bond length
of a simple molecule like calcium 1 or
fluoride we still get it off by a factor
of 2 even using the larger
supercomputers in the world to me this
has been very interesting this
recognition of all these problems we
cannot solve it's also true in
optimization problems there are the
bases of logistics and routing and you
know portfolio optimization these tons
and tons of problems in which at best we
do approximations but we're far from
optimal because the number of
possibilities is enormous so if there's
one message I want to be able to come
across is that we have these easy
problems which is the world where
classical computers fit
and the problems itself but then these
all they're hard problems that go
outside and if you don't believe that P
equals NP which I would say the majority
of mathematicians don't believe that
that is the case that those problems are
hard for a reason the only Avenue to go
and tackle that aside from
approximations will be through the
creation of quantum computers so where
are we we believe that small practical
quantum computers are going to be
possible and we're building them now it
requires reinventing the whole stack the
device is different it's not the
traditional transistors as an example
this is the device we use for the
quantum computers that we create at IBM
based on superconducting doses of
junctions and you're seeing an example
of one of these device is a
superconducting device and because it's
superconducting you have to cool it so
this is what a small quantum computer
looks like what you're seeing here is
something called a dilution refrigerator
and this quantum processor sits at the
bottom of this refrigerator at the nice
temperature of 15 Mille Kelvin so that
is colder than outer space where we have
to put this quantum processor in this is
what for example a 16 qubit quantum
processor looks like and you know inside
the you see the square where the qubits
are and you see these squiggly lines
which is these coupling resonators that
allow you to send the information
uncoupled to the qubits to send the
information this is what the wiring
looks like into the refrigerator going
into a quantum processor is these
coaxial cables and because the way you
stand information to a quantum processor
is to a series of microwave pulses that
go in and then you're able to take it
out now if you look at pictures of what
computers were like right in the 40s and
the 50s it's kind of like where we are
today
right that's what you know quantum
computer that's the signal processing
required to actually send all those
signals down the coaxial cables it look
like that but we've also seen this movie
before in the sense that we know how
much progress we have made from those
early system and while we don't
anticipate that quantum computers will
be on your phone because they require
cryogenic cooling we definitely believe
that access to quantum computers in the
cloud will be something that people will
be able to leverage behind the scenes
even not knowing because we believe that
we created a small quantum computer last
year and we made it available to the
world and something called the IBM
quantum experience and all of you can go
and log in and have access to this is
available for free it's a five qubit
machine and since we launched it we have
over 36,000 users from over a hundred
countries that have been doing it and
you know 15 scientific publications have
gone on it and people are learning how
to program and to learn about this new
world and what is being created and you
can actually run things on this so I was
telling you about these chemistry
problems so this is an example of the
expected theoretical calculation and the
actual calculation and a small quantum
machine of hydrogen so we're starting to
solve small problems and what is coming
in the years ahead in the next few years
will be machines that no classical
computer will be able to emulate because
by the time you have order of 50 cubits
think about that that's two to the 50
states and no classical machine will be
able to emulate what that can do and
that is new territory and that's the
territory we're all gonna enter and now
is the most interesting part because
it'll be the path of discovery of what
we can do and what value we can create
on problems we couldn't solve before so
I'll close with Fineman who proposed
this original idea of creating these
quantum machines and his you know
inimitable style
he said nature is in classical dammit
and if you want to make a simulation of
nature you met you better make it
quantum mechanical and by golly is a
wonderful problem the
because it doesn't look so easy thank
you
[Applause]